foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones here at AAA
825-5225 that's
888-825-5225 Jade I am so pumped we were
talking about it before we went on the
air the first smart conference ever at
the Ramsey Event Center the first event
at the Ramsey Event Center the brand new
Ramsey Event Center is this Friday and
Saturday and it is completely sold out
thank you America we appreciate that
there's gonna be about three thousand of
our closest friends hanging out with us
for the weekend a Friday evening all day
Saturday event and excited about that
and big news we announced yesterday that
we're going to stream the morning
sessions on Saturday morning free wow
hello free so that would be like George
Campbell
who just launched his new YouTube site
yesterday on Ramsay networks and Rachel
Cruz will be speaking and I'll be
yacking a little bit there in the
morning and uh so we'll set all of that
up and you guys are going to get the
first several sessions there in the
morning completely free just go to
ramsesolutions.com click on events and
look for the free live stream on
Saturday morning of the smart conference
I think it's the first time we've ever
done this and it's all from the Ramsay
Event Center I'm just pumped this is an
exciting exciting week for us I'm very
very excited
for your first smart conference too yes
the speaker that's right that's right so
Jake will be on the stage later in the
day on Saturday uh and as well as Dr
John deloney Ken Coleman me uh it's the
whole lineup all of the Ramsey
personalities will be there speaking and
teaching you on the different areas of
your life and uh it's a smart conference
so when you leave you will be smart yes
that's how that works and the live music
Dave can we just highlight there's music
like this is like energetic
you know we have people here that can
actually sing We Do You Yes
um John plays guitar
yeah and George George and George plays
guitar that's right legitimately insings
legitimately
and um and I play the radio that's right
and that's what I play and uh I can
imagine you playing a cowbell yeah no
you can't no you can't
oh open phone's here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Mary
starts this hour in Oklahoma City hey
Mary welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jane oh my gosh I'm so
excited to be here I really didn't think
they were gonna pick up when I called of
course we did we knew Mary was calling
they said Mary's on the phone we got
right on it
yeah
yeah Shin is I want to be a millionaire
by the time I hit 50 and I'm 46 going on
47 in September and my net worth right
now is 351. I'm on baby sick
baby step six and I owe 293 of my
mortgage and my network my um income my
last year uh 207 000. so you're 46.
I'm 46. okay and you have 350 000 in
your Investments and you're and you have
200 000 on your house owed what's the
house worth
uh
[Music]
485k okay all right so your net Worth's
about 500 000 give or take
hello I I yeah uh I I thought it was
351. no the equity in your house is is
towards your net worth you owe 400 I
mean you owe 200 it's worth 400 right so
about 200 Equity there and 350 is 500.
so you got you're about a half a million
and how much are you going to add to
this equation over the next four years
um
[Music]
and I want to be I want to pay off my
mortgage in two years but with inflation
and everything okay so you're going to
add a hundred thousand dollars a year
for four years to this equation first
two years pay off your mortgage and
after that to your Investments
are you
if you had four if you had a hundred
thousand dollars a year for four years
you're there
because you're already at 550.
plus 550 plus 4 is 950 and you're gonna
have some growth
[Music]
I didn't that's not fancy math that's
just quick first grade addition do you
understand what he did Mary he took your
net worth now which you you were not
calculating the equity in your home it
was 351 and then if you pay off your
house it's worth 4.85 you add that up
and then you're going to have growth
over time as well over the next four
years no no no okay you got 350. and
then you have a paid off house by the
time in two years correct that's worth
500. that's my goal okay but if you okay
that's a hundred a year for two years
right yeah okay if you do just a minute
stick with me okay if you have a paid
for 500 000 house two years from now you
add 350 to that is that not 8.50
thank you
hello are you there
okay I'm here that's how you do it and
then the next two years you add a
hundred
to your Investments if your Investments
don't grow at all if you add a hundred a
year for the next four years to this
total equation the first two years to
the house the next two years to
Investments you're over a million if the
Investments don't grow at all so yeah
you're gonna be there way to go kiddo
you killed it it's great proud of you
touchdown you did it you won the Super
Bowl now is a million dollars enough
that wasn't her question she just wants
to be a millionaire she just wants that
first Milestone to be there and uh and
and by age 50. so she's gonna actually
be a typical millionaire that we found
in the largest study a Millionaire's
ever done that Ramsay did and uh in that
basically we're going to find that just
a little less than half of her net worth
is in her home on the first million
dollars and the rest of it is in her
401k and in mutual fund Investments and
so that's how most of the one 1.5
million dollar net worth people we found
and oh by the way the average age was
52. that's great that's so young
it's getting younger every day yeah for
me it's just a puppy
it's more than young I can't believe
someone that young I knew anything
they're just young but yeah yeah that's
uh you did it that's how you do it so
you know and here's the interesting
thing okay
it's good to lay out your net worth and
not to obsess over it but to have goals
absolutely because then that causes you
to make positive moves towards hitting
your goals if you don't do in other
words whatever you don't do on purpose
languishes that's right intentionality
is everything in any area of your life
yep where there is no vision people
perish and you don't do anything at all
so you have a vision you got to go
through look at the numbers I think a
lot of people are afraid Dave to even
look at their retirement numbers or see
what it is that they can accomplish in
the time that they have set before them
yeah
I think you'd be surprised if you look
it really doesn't I mean you don't have
to spend like days and days and days on
this sure when you go okay now what have
I got to do what must be true for me to
put a hundred a year out of my two and a
quarter income on these you know for
four years I'm 46 so that at 50 ding
ding I'm there yeah way to go Mary very
proud of you good work this is the
Ramsay show
thank you
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Andrea is with us in Houston hey Andre
how are you
good how are you better than we deserve
how can we help
um so I've just started your University
and I've got all the materials I'm kind
of thinking a little bit ahead and I was
contemplating what to do with the two
cars I have
okay um basically they're both upside
down big time but I mean in a perfect
world I'd love to sell them both and get
a really cheap minivan that I can fit my
five kids what do you owe on the first
one
it's 37.
and what's it worth
um well one place one dealership called
me and said that they could pay 40 grand
for it but then the car backs and Max
whatever was saying like 30 like really
low 30s
okay well what's the other one yeah
it's the truck
um it's uh 47 on that one and um it's
definitely I could I know I can only get
like 30 probably 30 mid 30 for it okay
the Traverse is upgraded but the truck
isn't it's just the average
um uh Dodge Ram okay so have you let's
do a little bit more research on this
first car and find out if you can really
get 40 for it because if you can are you
looking at to just you're going down to
a one-car family or you
because you could take
the 3000 if you if it really is worth 40
put it towards a 47 and keep rolling or
if you're if you were wanting to sell
both at least that 3000 could go towards
the amount that you're upside down in
car number two
yeah well that's that's Dave's next
question is do you have any money set
aside whatsoever
no that's literally the plan so
um I have to still save the Thousand
emergency
um I've been I'm credit cards are
starting to get paid down and I plan to
cut the first one this next week and so
I'm kind of
still thinking aside though because I
want to attack this pretty um intensive
so your plan was to sell both cars what
was your plan after that I guess I'm
trying to get on your train of thought
because I can tell you what I would do
but
sell both and get a cash for a car like
a minivan that I can fit all 5K okay and
then uh what does your husband Drive
I'm divorced you're divorced oh so you
own two cars with one driver
right oh okay and what's your household
it sounds like
um right now
um I'm the self-employed business owner
and so after business expense and my cut
basically after employees it's um 120 a
year good okay
good
so you're you're on it I love your
intensity thank you thank you thank you
you're going to go places you're going
to be okay so
um well do you how how bad is your
credit
um it was close to 740 and now it's down
to a 650 because I've chosen to pay
other stuff rather than credit cards
um
do you have uh who's the truck loan with
who do you owe the money on the truck to
Wells Fargo so it's a good bank and it's
a good interest rate
no it's not a good thing but it is a
bank you know it's not a bank that's
going broke but um okay so what I would
do is Trot over to is Wells Fargo got a
branch there that you work with
um I kind of ordered the car online so I
mean I could look for a branch of nearby
what I want to do is talk Wells Fargo
and I would prefer to do it in person
talk Wells Fargo into letting you sign a
note for whatever the truck doesn't
bring
so that approximately twenty thousand
dollars or so hopefully you can get more
than 30 for it hopefully your your data
is wrong and you get into KBB and you do
a private sale and you get 35 or 37 then
you're only 10 in the hole Yeah but you
would borrow that 10 from Wells Fargo
and uh then they would release the title
to the buyer because you've got to sign
a note for the difference in other words
they're making you the equivalent of a
personal loan which they already have
they're just admitting it okay because
the truck's not worth enough to cover in
the event of a repo so they're already
not they already don't have sufficient
collateral and they're just allowing you
to get rid of the debt which ensures
that you're actually going to pay the 10
or the 12 or the 15 or whatever the
difference is so that's what I want to
start with is try to get them to cover
let you sign a note for the difference
how much other debt other than cars do
you have
credit cards personal loans and student
loan which
um how much credit card so the credit
cards are probably totaling about 10
grand left to pay good personal loan is
about 10 grand as well because I have
two they're small perfect
um and then the student loan used to be
twenty thousand now it's 9 000. okay so
I paid that down okay so what I want to
temporarily stop paying on the student
loan completely who's the personal loans
with
first of all it's sincerely companies
called opportune and reprise they were
basically when
um because I have four months with my
work and so I didn't have emergency
savings or any kind of Bill savings
until I got personal loans out
okay I'm just wondering if they would
loan you the money to get out of that
car if Wells Fargo won't
try it off they would
no I'm not talking about if you pay it
off I'm talking about the ten thousand
dollar hole the difference 15 or whole
year in on the truck oh I'm trying to
get rid of that truck today and you've
got to give Wells Fargo forty seven
thousand dollars to get the title to
that truck to sell it in order to do
that you've got to cover the difference
the amount you're in the hole if Wells
Fargo won't let you sign a note for the
difference you've got to find another
bank or credit union you need to loan
you that that's why I was fishing around
for so okay now yeah I'm selling selling
both of them if I can find a way to
cover the truck deficit by borrowing
that amount and then you're going to uh
that's going to get rid of way more than
half of your debt uh and yeah scrape
together the cash with the difference on
the van and whatever other cash you if
you have to stop uh debt snowballing for
a minute and uh get you a five thousand
dollar van yeah right I hope you can get
five more for the van than it's worth
and then you can just go get a five
thousand dollar van then we can get the
truck sold that's going to leave you 10
or 15 in the hole then you've got 10 on
credit cards 10 on personal loans and 20
on or nine on student loans left so you
know you're going to be out of debt
really really fast with your intensity
and your intentionality you're really
doing good really good that's exciting
I'm excited it's not even my situation
yeah she's really taking action so let
me tell you what when you start saying
I'll do whatever it takes and you mean
it yep for towards any goal you're going
to get the gold yeah well she's you can
tell she didn't say what it was but
she's got a reason and it's it's very
clear what her reason is and why she's
got to do this and why she's got to act
so intensely and that's really the
difference between her and somebody who
calls in you know lollygagging through
this thing yeah it's probably pretty
easy to surmise the stinking truck was
her exes heck yeah oh yeah so that thing
is there's a lot of reasons to be pissed
with that truck but the uh yeah getting
rid of that and wow and then cleaning up
this mess with your 120 000 income in
one year you're going to be in such a
different place because you're willing
to amputate these vehicles where you're
willing to get rid of them and so you
got to set up the deficit you got to
cover that deficit and then you're going
to be fine very good all right Jeannie's
in New Jersey hi Jeannie how are you
better than I deserve
um anyway I I just um I had a question I
hope it doesn't sound stupid I'm kind of
doing this by myself and um I did go
through FPU I didn't have the best
experience but I I'm smart enough to to
know
how to eat the meat and throw away the
bones if you know what I'm saying so I I
went through the course I feel like I
went through steps one through three
relatively easy and I'm wondering is
there ever a time when it's okay to be
intense to I need to buy a house very
soon and is it okay to be intense in
Step six I'm kind of since I never
really felt that I'm kind of interested
in what these bones you're talking about
but um I'll say that till the end ah you
know I think some people they go through
one through three quickly or maybe they
had something they were able to sell or
it's not as much of a process so if you
want to go quicker through baby steps
four five and six that's up to you we
tell folks they don't have to be intense
but if you want to be you know that's up
to you if you want to get there quicker
you know do your thing I'm not mad at
that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 percent off selected
products visit blinds.com today for more
info
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phone's a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Calum is with us in a Denver area hi
Calum how are you
how about you better than I deserve
what's up
well I'm looking at starting a drone
spraying business actually it was kind
of my grandpa's idea and he owns a
pretty large
farm and
um I guess I'm just trying to figure out
how to start at debt free
I have about thirty thousand dollars in
a 529 plan because I decided not to go
to college
and um I've also got about 15 000 saved
up and I need about 45 to buy the
equipment
so drone I guess I'm just one wait a
minute how old are you
19. cool okay so drone let me get this
straight because I'm pretty ignorant
about what you're talking about but I
think I got the idea you've got the
drones that are big enough to carry
insecticide or some or or fertilizer
liquid form to fly over a farm and spray
like a modern version of a biplane
yep that's correct wow how big is this
freaking drone dude
oh it's about loaded with chemical it'll
be about 200 pounds and how many how
many acres how fast is it how efficient
is it
they're saying you can do 40 acres an
hour
and then you got to reload right
yeah but you can it's just so it's it's
sprays about it has a 10 gallon tank it
goes out and sprays it comes back you
swap the battery fill it up go back out
it's just kind of a cycle you just keep
going but you can do about a 300 acre
acre field and they're saying about
eight hours so it's not really fast fast
but around our area there's only about
two planes that can fly out and they're
super packed
um up in the summer so well and you've
got Mountain Rangers to Dodge in your
area oh my gosh that's so cool I love
this idea okay how many acres has your
Grandpa got
oh he has about 5 000 on the farm but
only about oh I'd say a thousand are
um actual Fields so what does he pay for
someone to do the uh do the spraying now
uh it's about 13 to 14 an acre
13 to 14.
yes dollars an acre yep
yeah so you can make about 300 bucks per
hour with the Drone no no I'm just
getting I'm just trying to get my total
pricing right so you could get somewhere
around 12 to 15 000 for doing a thousand
acres
yeah how many times a year does your
grandfather have that sprayed
well it depends that's the thing it
depends on
um what you're spraying see corn you
would spray you could spray at least two
times a year
um it just depends on like Alfalfa you
can get
um where where you cut it for
um hay you could spray it when it gets
bugs in it and stuff I mean you could
spray anything with it so you could give
me an average I'm trying to lay out a
business model here I'm not trying to
learn the agricultural part of it how
many times does the typical farmer spray
the typical Thousand Acre field one two
ten times a year
I would say one a year one time a year
is a typical okay and you need forty
five thousand dollars
so would your grandfather consider
prepaying you for his first or second
spraying
yeah I could see that as a uh yeah if
you got that right that's if you did too
that's like 30 grand and you already
have 15 we just did this
yeah
um I mean his his Acres aren't as big
for the um for his field so I would I
would definitely have to go out and find
other people well get somebody else and
here's the thing if you go to some your
grandpa was gonna do it because he wants
to help you
okay because he's it's money he's going
to pay anyway the only thing he's losing
is he's going to pay it early to get his
grandson's deal up and running okay so
get him to pay you for two sprays up
front
whatever it is okay now let's say that
you've got a neighbor that has a twelve
thousand dollar deal because it's a one
uh one thousand acres to be sprayed okay
you with me I'm using example you can
change the numbers to be more reality
then go to that neighbor that's a friend
of your grandpa's and say hey I'm trying
to get this up and running I'm 19 I'm a
young business guy I'm not going to
borrow money and instead of doing that I
want to pre-sell you and you prepay for
your twelve thousand dollar spraying the
great news is I'm only going to charge
you nine for this one if you prepay me
yeah that that's actually I didn't even
think about that really and they will um
well that's why I'm here and they will
because I've I've never done drone
spraying business but I'm about to this
is I love this you're so cool Caleb you
are you man you're amazing cool so what
a great young entrepreneur yeah get in
other words what I have done in the past
I've got customers to prepay me I give
them a discount to do that and that
gives me all the money to do the deal
and I don't have to do deal with some
stupid butt bank and I don't have
interest and I don't have to take the
money out of my 529 and get the
government taking half of it in
penalties and interest which I don't
want to do that either so you noticed I
was avoiding the 529.
um and here's the worst thing that could
happen is you have to spray all these
fields and this doesn't work out and
you've got some paid for drones true
that figure out something else to do
with them
but I mean you can take pictures with
them you can do a lot of stuff with them
and because these are Monster drones
yeah if they're lugging 200 pounds
that's a
fly me around
there we go look at Mom no hay rides
over the field no not really but yeah I
mean oh my gosh that's pretty impressive
that is that's very very young
entrepreneur great creative strategy too
and let me tell you this folks I um
between what we do on the Ramsey show
and what we do with the entree
leadership I'm running into so many
entrepreneurs that are under 30 that are
not stupid they are not lacking in work
ethic they are hard-working smart
they've got good ideas they're thinking
that young guys being wise he calls us
how can I do this debt free I'm so
excited about the future of America
to
there's options out there you can't you
know go through with tunnel vision but
these people are just going what do I
like doing what do I know about doing
what am I good at doing and usually
that's going to lead you down some
pretty uh lucrative paths if you allow
it to okay Caleb I'm going to send you a
copy of entree leadership my number one
best-selling book on how we started this
business on a card table in my living
room and how we run it up to this day
maybe it'll help you keep going because
you're an amazing young guy John is with
us in Minneapolis hi John welcome to the
Ramsey Show
how's it going today better than I
deserve what's up
wondering if I should rent for a season
and sell my house because it's way over
the 25 you recommend
what's your payment and how much do you
take home each month
so I bring home about 4 500 on a month
but I don't have any overtime
and currently my mortgage payment is
17.35 on a 15 year
with about 12 and a half years ago
but I also have one of those helocs that
Dave loves that brings brings me up to
another 775
to a total of 25 10 a month which is
about 55 what do you owe on the HELOC
uh 62 000.
what for
all the usual stuff I did uh
consolidation in the past because the
other part wasn't going to cost you your
house this stupid stuff cost you your
house
and that's that's exactly where I'm at
with it
do you have any other debt
3 700 that I'm in babe sub 2 will be
done by about the 15th of May
you said 3 700. all right correct
because I was going to get it continued
to be gazelle intense on the HELOC but
how fast can you knock it out if you if
you crank the overtime
one and a half to two years so you like
your house
um I would prefer to say here yes
bust it for 18 months and clear the
HELOC shoe
yeah yeah that's just HELOC is just an
extension of your debt snowball because
all the stuff that would have been in
your debt snowball got rolled up in that
and I don't want that to be the cause of
you selling your house I'd rather you
bust that death snowball in the mouth
about being intense for another 18
months keep your house since you like it
and it's a good house yeah that's what I
would do good question sir this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today if
you're new to this Ramsay show stuff and
many of you are based on our huge
increase in ratings and rankings thank
you for visiting us and thank you for
all of you telling people about the show
too we really appreciate you if you're
new and you're trying to figure out what
all these words and baby steps and death
snowballs and stuff means and the code
around here uh we'll help you get
started it's completely free go to
ramsesolutions.com click the get started
button and that'll get you started we'll
help you figure out where you are and
what your next best steps are again
completely free click get started at
ramseysolutions.com our question of the
day is sponsored by neighborly your hub
for Home Services Summer's busy makes it
hard to find someone for Home
Maintenance sometimes but neighborly is
your source for local repair
professionals like air serve Mr electric
dryer vent wizard go to neighborly.com
and be ready for any season April is
National financial literacy month and
all month long teachers and students in
classrooms Across America are taking
time to talk about the importance of
learning good money skills one search
student sends in our question of the day
that's right we got today's question
that's coming from Brittany in Arizona
she says if I'm trying to get into my
dream college and I get in but I don't
get a scholarship should I still go or
should I try to get a full scholarship
from another College
this is a very good question well you
know at the end of the day the goal is
to go to college debt free right we
don't want to go into into debt for our
education and I don't know how much this
school costs but if you're not getting a
scholarship there you know the next box
to take is to say well is there any way
that I can work through this and pay the
tuition as I go
um so that's the next option and get a
job and do that whole thing and if
that's out of the picture like I don't
know if we're talking about ivy league
or I don't know if we're talking about
you know local State College what the
situation is but if you're not able to
pay cash for it we need to start looking
at other options is basically what this
boils down to yeah if you're going to go
in debt to go your dream college is
actually a nightmare yeah that I know
that I know that firsthand
so that's number one number two Brittany
I think this is a good chance for you to
get a little bit
um
philosophical and say okay why is my
dream College my dream College why is it
my dream what makes it your favorite
what makes it exciting and many times
and I'm not necessarily sure that's true
about Brittany but it could be many
times
when we say our Dream something we're
basing it on something that is not real
well it's a red flag yeah it's a red
flag when I hear that so if my dream
college is a big name fancy School
then I that means I think if I go to
that school I'm going to be more likely
to be successful because I have that
name yeah well let me help you with that
dream Brittany that dream is called a
lie
because there's absolutely zero research
none and there's tons of research out
there not one piece of data
says that where you went to school
indicates your increased probability of
success that's right not one
I want
lots of failures at life
went to Harvard
went to Yale went to MIT
lots of them that's true and they
completely flunked out at life their
life sucks they suck and where they went
to school didn't fix that
it's you where you go to school there's
zero indication no none well I'm gonna
hang out with people and bullcrap well
I'm gonna go to Harvard Law whoopee yeah
you know listen the network is the big
that's the one people like well
the number of people you run around with
25 years after you got out of school
that went to school with you is
precisely zero come on and y'all were
drinking together anyway y'all were
y'all weren't y'all weren't thinking
about how to be successful hello beer
pong does not constitute a friendship
when people say dream when they say
dream College dream house dream vacation
dream car you're getting ready you're
getting ready to get getting ready to
get in a wreck that is your excuse me
for the second reason you could have a
dream School
is for another wrong reason to pick a
college and that could be the social
environment of that college true that
yeah it's got a great football team
they got a lazy river their their
facilities are beautiful the campus is
pretty yeah the town is pretty good
looking guys zero percent of this has to
do with your future
zero
no one ever
became successful in life because the
school they went to was a great party
school and had a great football team
zero percent
zero percent I went to that school and
because they played football well I am
successful what no what no no no no in
life you're actually going to have to do
your job and be good at your job and
show up on time for your job like you're
gonna have to not excuse me of this but
I am accusing lots of people who are
considering their dream school but most
of the time it comes down to they think
they are getting Superior academics and
Superior Prestige that is going to give
them a superior chance towards success
and there's zero data data that says
that yeah because here's what truly
happens
if you are going to be successful after
you graduate
you will spend the next 25 years of your
life being a continual learning person a
person of continue to learn so good you
will get the equivalent of three more
degrees because you read you attend
conferences and classes you continue
your professional growth that's right if
you graduate from college and never read
another book you become what's known as
a stupid human
[Laughter]
you are not trending towards success
it's true really it's true I didn't go
to the best music school and I remember
that my classmates were going to and I
know people that are special music
schools who cannot sing they suck hello
I'm just saying you know at the end of
the day you got to be the one that works
hard like Dave said you got to be the
one that furthers your education it is
not and nobody ever asked me for my
degree by the way yeah I listen I I was
at the doctor the other day and they
were getting ready to do some minor
surgery and I did not ask to see where
he went to school you didn't stop them
before they put you know the needle and
go wait
um
didn't even do that with the last three
lawyers I hired all I wanted to know is
are you smart and are you mean and can
you win okay that's all I wanted to know
about the lawyer okay I don't care when
I went to law school are you smart are
you mean and can you win that's a fact
lawyers if you're going to go to court
you need to be smart me and win right
yeah and so oh my gosh you know this is
this is what this is how you decide this
so
parents
stop this lingo now Brittany again I'm
not making fun of you personally because
I don't know that any of that is true
about you you did not indicate that in
your question that's right okay so I'm
I'm but I'm using that as a springboard
for this uh platform to say folks
my forever home
let me tell you there's only one forever
home it's heaven
that's it that's the word otherwise you
don't have a forever home your butt's
gonna move again
at least to the nursing home
again every time I move into a forever
home 12 to 15 years later I'm gone again
that's right it's the dream home your
dreams change we used to build dream
homes we had on the sign when I was 22
years old I worked for a home builder on
the side it said build your dream home
here you know what I discovered by the
time we finished the house their dreams
had changed yeah well that sign what
they want that sign to say is your
permission to go crazy and spend what
you want to spend here that's what that
is well because I'm only gonna do it
once so I might as well go all in yeah
you know the other part of this just
occurred to me the vernacular of my
dream something you know what that says
yeah you can't tell me I can't oh
because you're a dream killer that is
good this is I you have to live in your
truth yes
other people can't question you if you
say it's my dream home it's my dream
it's my dream school because no one is
allowed to be a dream killer oh yeah
life will be Simon Cowell if you don't
have it out there okay someone will come
along and tell you your dream's stupid
that's a stupid dream don't do it it's
gonna be a nightmare so sometimes when
they say dream school that's what they
mean so I'm just helping your parents
some of you Educators go ahead and kill
their dreams now yes and get them to
reality let's get an education and
something that's actually usable or we
can complete the four-year degree jade
look if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show
but we help people build wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Paul is with us in Las Vegas hi
Paul how are you
uh I'm doing good how about you better
than I deserve what's up
so uh my question is
um what are some of the most efficient
side hustles you could think of because
I've tried uh like driving side hustles
such as like instacart and door
dashboard seems to cost more in gas then
it seems to like earn money
um so just to give you like backstory
um so I make over 38 000 a year and I
also get a disability patient VA so
that's uh like thirteen thousand seven
hundred dollars a year uh however so I'm
in the middle of a divorce and so I only
get half of my paycheck from my job
and um per temporary court orders since
uh September of 2021 I've also had to
pay the mortgage on the house that my ex
and my kids have been living in
um so I've actually got half your check
and you pay the house
yes
on top of that I'm actually technically
in Pahrump but uh we do my parents and I
have been living with my parents for
Less
a few years we will be closing on a
house in Vegas uh in the on the 25th but
in the meantime who's we
uh my parents my parents will be closing
on the house but I've been living with
them
okay but you're not on it you're not on
the loan
no okay
okay I'm just saying like you know we
collectively but anyways so in the
meantime I've been driving like an hour
and 20 minutes to and from work uh and
have have shelbon's ass three times a
week
and uh my house is currently getting
fixed up to get sold
um and uh it actually it'll be done like
really soon within like the next week or
two uh but I do have to pay a thousand
dollar deductible to the contractor and
a thousand dollars to the handyman
and uh I have over 16 800 in debt
um
the first one is a bank loan money hours
the house that your wife is living in
soon to be your ex is being sold
voluntarily
um and moved she and she and the kids
moved into her Grandma's trailer
I I had nothing to do with that but we
we both agreed to sell the house for
mediation okay so the house you're
paying payments on for her is not for
her it's for you you're gonna sell it
yes and how much money will it get will
you get out of it when you sell it
um we're trying to we're going to try
and sell for um 180k and what do you owe
on it
um
and all that I don't have information on
that sorry well I mean do you owe 180 or
do you owe 80 I mean roughly
um I want to say like um 120k okay so
you're gonna get 60. 20 30 000 bucks a
piece so you'll be able to pay off your
debt and she'll get you're going to
split the house Equity I assume
yes okay good okay so then really what
you're going to come down to is you're
going to be debt free with the sale of
your house and with your divorce
everything will be settled and you'll be
able to just pay child support at that
point which you should do and I'm assume
you're more than willing to do that and
then all you've got is a career question
am I right
oh well so I'm going to be uh going back
to school uh I know you're not you're
broke
no I know I'm going back to school on
the GI Bill oh I'll get housing
allowance uh from from that and um I'm
actually gonna work towards the
communications uh degree to go into
copywriting okay so if you quit work and
went and did that now would that not
solve your problem
to the um into the copywriting industry
no I mean you're going to go to school
and they're going to pay you a stipend
and they're going to pay for your
housing and they're going to pay for
school out of the GI Bill correct
and you're living with your parents so
you don't have any overhead
um right I don't know if we have to
drive for instacart
it doesn't seem like it you've got and
you've got the disability coming in
right um it's just that um you know I
calculated my um uh my budget for uh for
next month and based on that I'm only
going to get able to give squeeze out
like 500 for um for savings and that
will have to go towards
uh team that
um pains but that's just that Paul
that's just that month until you get
your house sold
right so for one month Whoopi do that
you've got six you've got 17 000 in debt
right once you sell this house you'll be
able to clear that debt there'll be a
few thousand left over you can put that
as your emergency savings over time
you'll be able to build it yeah to work
enough with your disability to pay your
child support and get in school and get
going
um you should be fine with that
um I think what's happening is what I
think I'm hearing Paul and I could be
wrong what I think I'm hearing is you've
got a
uh the normal emotions around a divorce
which is um
a broken heart and anger yeah and
you've got
um
a disability from your military service
thank you for your service
and in the middle of all of that
um you've got 43 balls in the air yeah
and all I'm doing while we're talking is
taking each one and setting them out of
the air on the table and then there's
really not that much in the air anymore
you just sound uh
overwhelmed by the whole situation and
it's translating down into this career
thing that's not even really an issue I
really think
mall but I think it would go a long way
for him to write down yes first I'm
going to do this next I'm going to do
like write down everything that we
talked about today and that's your
solution and just getting it out of your
head having it written down you have a
written plan that's going to make you
feel a lot better tonight yeah that'll
help you go with the whole how do you
eat an elephant thing a bite at a time
because all I was doing was walking
through prioritization in your life what
do you got to do we got to eat we gotta
have housing you know we've got to do
this we got to do that and how do we lay
out our future we can survive a few
months of
you know 500 or 200 or whatever and the
house gets sold clears up everything we
get the divorce settled done we've got
the established child support
um the job you're driving in an hour and
a half for you don't need no and
especially when you're not making
anything with the courts taking half of
that money yeah so I mean that that's
the process I would look at and uh you
know how you need to make sure you're
taking care of your kids that's all I'm
concerned about here and that you take
care of you and your future and that you
execute step by step by step through
this so Jade's exactly right write it
all out and I think you'll develop a bit
of a flow chart on how to walk through
each of these decisions this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five well taxes are upon us
folks April the 18th Tuesday will be the
federal tax return deadline you've got
to get your paperwork together you got
to get your act together April October
16th is the deadline if you request an
extension uh however always bear in mind
you cannot request an extension on
payment if you owe taxes and you do not
pay them by April the 18th you will have
penalties and late charges even if you
file an extension that's a good point a
lot of people don't realize that
so the income tax brackets went up in
2022 to account for inflation and will
likely go up again in 23. the more a
taxpayer earns the more their earnings
are subject to a higher rate well it's
always been that way we've got a whole
explainer if you want to go and learn
how the tax brackets work at
ramseysolutions.com taxes
lots of other stuff going on that's
right it says that the IRS is also
telling people that you should expect
less this year you know in the prior
years especially those years Dave after
2020 uh there were all of those economic
impact packages we got more of the child
tax credit uh that we saw in good news
is the pandemic is over and so what goes
along with that is there's none of these
extra payments expanded tax credits and
deductions like the tax credit and the
charitable contributions deductions
reverted to their pre-coven 19 amounts
uh so taxpayers will not get this extra
stimulus money uh and that's something
worth noting and then I like this one it
says how can people save money this tax
season well this is basically the same I
guess every tax season you get your tax
deductions and your tax credits so tax
deductions are helping you lower the
amount of your income that can actually
be taxed and then so those are things
like medical charitable contributions
business expenses that sort of thing
then you've got your tax credit that are
actually dollar amounts that are
subtracted from the end of your tax bill
which is great because they're
refundable so you've got things like the
Earned Income Tax Credit the child tax
credit uh education credit those sorts
of things so and here's the deal with
the if you're married filing jointly
you're up over 28 000 now on the
standard deduction which means you would
have to have itemized deductions in
excess twenty eight thousand to even
bother to itemize what type of person is
itemizing uh someone who has a large
deductions and or has a lot of has a
business
um has a lot of things like that but
it's only about 12 percent right now 88
or not so it's a you know and so like
your home mortgage interest is
deductible
but not unless you
don't claim the standard deduction if
you claim the standard deduction then
it's you know part of it it was uh you
just gave the bank some monies all you
did so um this thing I'm not paying off
my home mortgage because it's tax
deductible for 88 percent of you that's
an absolute bull crap line
uh it's just not true because you're not
deducting the interest because you're
taking the standard deduction instead so
that's that's the whole thing and you do
not want a big refund
this is the that's the moral of the
story this is the biggest con to have
ever been put out on the American public
someone convinced grown-ups that Santa
Claus lives in Washington DC that this
money is coming to you
as if it isn't a refund you know how you
get a refund first you fund it and then
they refund it yeah so a refund is when
you take a shirt back at the store and
they refund your money that you gave
them earlier yeah
refund oh my God how dumb are we yeah
we're walking around I got a big refund
what's that mean it means you paid in
too much all year long and got no
interest on your money while it's
Saturday in Washington D.C that's dumber
than a rock you don't want a big refund
that means you're a big dummy don't do
that big refund means you paid in too
much but Dave that's my vacation fund
well but save your vacation fund at the
credit union for God's sakes you know I
mean really but Dave how am I supposed
to buy my big screen TV uh save up for
it with the money you don't send to the
government
by not overpaying your taxes all year
long and then getting it back in April
and acting like Santa Claus brought you
a gift okay I know Santa Claus I'm old
he's a friend of mine he does not live
in Washington D.C he even detests going
to Washington DC because he figures
they're all bad little boys and girls
there anyway so there you go I'm just
saying
so I'm just sure that the refund had
nothing to do with charity
yeah none yeah nothing NADA don't get a
bit so if you got a 2400 refund that
means you paid in 200 a month too much
out of your paycheck every month that
could have been money in your actual
lifestyle
you could have paid off debt with it
debt snowball yeah man I'd rather have
it in my money you could have paid for
your increased gas prices
yeah
yeah because when you when you let you
let the refund come here you are saying
two things you're saying I don't mind
loaning this money with no interest
which I don't think people really
understand that and two you're saying
that I need this money because I can't
save money myself to do the things that
I want to do like go on vacation or buy
that TV because that's what people do
they get this big hunk of money and they
use it to do dumb stuff yeah because
they act like it's like the lottery or
something like all it was was like you
put twenty dollars in your coat and you
forgot it yeah and you put the coat on
next winter and put your hand in there
and you go oh
that's all it is that's right that's
exactly oh surprise surprise yeah look
at me I'm rich at least when you find it
in your pocket it's got some lint or
like a a Cheez-It or something it is
your pocket so you know who the dummy
was that's right yeah so that's the
thing so if you're ready to file your
check taxes and you need to be ready to
file your taxes it's coming like this
weekend so uh you need to check out
Ramsay smart tax uh it lets you file
online with low upfront pricing and no
hidden fees plus you can save up to 70
percent when you switch from other
software go to ramseysolutions.com
smarttax we also have a tax guide blog
article and a tax prep checklist at
ramseysolutions.com taxes and we have
tax professionals that are endorsed
local providers if you have a
complicated return yes they'll walk you
through it so just click on tax ELP at
ramsaysolutions.com we can help you all
the way around
we're not charging you extra and we're
not uh Turbo Tax which is going to try
to sell you a credit card yes that's
right they're going to try to get you in
debt
yeah they're real that's actually the
business they're in so let's just be
real clear yeah and so I mean what you
can be assured that nothing from Ramsay
is going to try to get you into debt
that's uh we're quite the opposite
around here all right Dave's in Boise hi
Dave welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey how's it going guys better than we
deserve what's up
so I just need some recommendations and
uh on how to pay off my current mortgage
uh faster I've got some options from my
mortgage company and then I got some
options from investors but I want to
hear your take because my wife said you
have all the answers
I wish my wife would say that
that's funny
uh well I I don't have an answer but I'm
an expert on my opinion so I can do that
for you
um here's the thing
the main goal either way
at the end of the story is which way it
causes me to build wealth
with the highest probability of it
really happening and the fastest
shortest distance between two points is
a straight line right so what what is
the fastest right way to build wealth
not according to Legend or Theory but
actual data and so that's the way I
would couch the answer to this and so I
would go to the Ramsey millionaire study
where we studied ten thousand
Millionaires and we asked them how they
became millionaires the number of them
that said we put money in an investment
account in order to pay off our mortgage
faster was very close to zero
the vast majority of them said we
steadily invested in our 401K while we
paid off our house as fast as we could
just by paying extra mortgage payments
very simple and so there's no fancy
way that you can trick the interest
rates yeah big hairy principal payments
big chunks on the mortgage makes the
debt go away you can't trick the math
that much there's no big math trick on
this so just pay off your house as fast
as you can that's what the data says
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
straight wash all Ramsay personality is
my co-host Jay is in Savannah hi Jay
welcome to the Ramsay show
how's it going uh Jade and Dave honored
to speak to both of you I just got a
question for you I have a side hustle
business that is making a good amount of
money right now and um I'm all in when
it comes to the joining of finances
through marriage but I wanted some kind
of clarity and clarification since
they're not the baby steps aren't
necessarily directly applicable to uh
you know say your business
um does the joining Finance is part of
the baby steps does that apply to say
your business account if that question
makes sense
not really I mean if you're thinking
about from the from the aspect that
you're taking money out of the business
as your payroll and then that's going
into your personal account yes but if
you run a business like my husband runs
a talent agency and I know what's going
on in the business but I'm not
you know I have access to the account I
suppose if I wanted to see it but I'm
not I'm not in there making withdrawals
and I'm not you're on the account I'm on
it that's what he's asking okay that's
what that's the ownership okay that's
kind of what I'm getting now Insurance
on all the Ramsay accounts
okay all of them
and she has no idea what's in them or
how to access them right none whatsoever
she doesn't come down here I mean she
was here today for lunch with her nieces
but that's I mean she doesn't come down
here not because we're mad at her not
but she just doesn't care well that's
what I'm saying that's another thing and
but if I die
um or if you know something happened to
our marriage she is half owner of all of
this
okay that that makes that makes sense uh
so you would say
um kind of have their name on the
business account
um but not necessarily involved with
um you know the inner workings of the
business well and here's the other thing
if I'm if I'm in Mexico and Sharon's
here
and they need her to come down here and
sign a check she can
that's a good point okay so I mean
there's all kinds of the banker could
she could authorize something for the
banker if I'm sick I mean you don't want
just one person on an account that's you
need to have someone else that can act
in your in this case she's not going to
be involved in the transactions crap I
don't sign the checks I'm machine signs
them now yeah so uh around here but uh
of course we I mean our payables are
massive yeah and so uh uh but yeah you
um
yes uh as far as ownership goes all of
the llc's that we have that we hold
different Assets in including real
estate and so forth uh Sharon is on all
of those and on all of the accounts and
again
if it wasn't she'd have to call our
controller uh who handles our personal
stuff as well uh if something happened
or she needed access to something to
find out what's going on who happens to
be one of her good friends too but
that's that's a side issue she keeps she
keeps Debbie pretty close
yeah as far as philosophically
from a practical tactical thing zero
involvement but philosophically the own
and legally the ownership should be
shared and uh and it's it's hers it's
hers as much as it's mine even though
I'm the one that runs the business
that's right that's good he mentioned
the baby steps and that kind of thing
but that's not really for business
that's well baby steps don't have
anything to do with whether you should
have joined accounts or not right but I
think I what I derived from it was like
I'm like I'm not speaking into Sam's
how he's spending the money in the
business it's not part of my day-to-day
I'm just on the accounts
Sharon she does not she does not know
where we buy copier paper yeah you know
it doesn't come up it doesn't come up at
dinner yeah so Jason is with us Jason is
in Anchorage Alaska hi Jason welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi Dave and Jade thanks for having me I
appreciate your time I'm a fairly uh new
listener and um I'm calling in to get a
little advice on you on what I should be
doing with my savings to make it work
for me other than what I'm currently
doing with it
I have about 170 000 in a high yield
saving account at about five percent so
I'm earning about somewhere between 700
to 740 in interest a month
um
a nice savings
yeah thank you what should I be doing
with it to make it work for me other
than what I'm doing currently should I
be investing in eye bonds should I be
investing in the stock market should I
be looking into purchasing real estate
what's the purpose of the savings are
you saving for a home or is this just
money that you like having around
um honestly in the latter
um it's it's just savings currently so
no debt nothing like that
um I'm currently debt free
um I do not own any properties currently
um I have a Roth 401 has about 42 000 in
it I have a 401k that has about 22 000
in it okay and you said it's 117 170
000 is that correct
correct Dave okay so if you made ten
percent off that'd be 17 000 a year and
you're currently making about eight
thousand a year
roughly yeah okay so you're losing about
ten thousand dollars a year by not
having it invested
in good mutual funds yeah so I would sit
down with a smart investor Pro and get
this money invested in some good mutual
funds and start earning north of ten
percent on average year in and year out
uh which is about ten thousand dollars a
year difference in what you're doing
right now
so your high yield savings is uh what
about four percent
I think it's 5.02 percent right yeah
okay yeah we'll keep that and
inflation's running nine so you're going
backwards
make sure you do keep aside three to six
months for normal
emergency fund purposes you have an
emergency rainy day fund in addition to
this
actually yes I left that out I I do have
an emergency fund of I think 42 000
right now yeah you need to get with a
smartvestor pro at ramsaysolutions.com
sit down start learning about mutual
funds and what we're discussing here
Jason is a concept in investing called
opportunity cost
when you put the money in a fruit jar
and it could have been making ten
percent and it's a hundred thousand
dollars you missed the opportunity for
that one hundred thousand dollars to
make ten thousand dollars a year
that's lost opportunity cost or if you
take a hundred thousand dollars and go
buy a new Mercedes with it
instead of investing you not only have a
car that's going down in value now but
you also lost the opportunity the
opportunity cost on the money is
whatever it could have earned in a good
investment call it ten percent for this
example my personal mutual funds do
considerably more than ten percent
average per year haven't lately no I
know the Market's down I'm aware but I
don't sell when it's down I buy when
it's down because it's on sale so I'm
investing this money with a long-term
mentality uh and writing out downturns
sit it out let it come back up and
you'll make a good average that's well
in excess of your high yield savings
account the interesting thing about the
high yield savings account is the very
name is an oxymoron high yield it's not
really that high
yeah it's yeah yeah the inflation rate
by the way for the last 75 years has
averaged 4.2 before we got into this
last Biden inflation run
this is when you've got that money
sitting there obviously the worst place
for it to be is like in a can in your
backyard because you're just losing
you're losing out on it it's not worth
that because of the inflation but even
just sitting in a high yield savings
account people think oh I'm doing great
I've got five percent or four and a half
months because you could only get one
before yeah these high-yield savings
accounts are doing really well if you've
got some shorts if you've got some
short-term money you want to park for
like a year sure you're gonna buy a
house next year yeah well that's that's
like five percent's a lot more than one
percent that's good but that's not a
good long-term play right even for a
couple of years though saving for a
house right up to about sure four or
five years you could do that absolutely
I completely agree yeah but the thing is
what you don't want to do is say over a
period of 10 15 20 years yeah I'm gonna
make five percent while inflation runs
four and after taxes and inflation I'm
going backwards yeah you're going way
far back yeah and especially when we're
in a nine percent inflationary Market
yeah so um yeah yeah because this is
real out there right now this uh this
crazy screwed up backward economy yeah
yeah it's uh simultaneously there's
people doing really good in one area of
their life and they're losing their
butts in another area of their life with
the stuff that's going on so you have to
really be careful and steady and wise
and predictable and this is where money
comes from
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host this day here on the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're so glad
you're here open phone's a triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
like the show help us by clicking the
Subscribe or follow button on your
YouTube or podcast screen please that'll
be a big help leave a five star review
mama said if you ain't got anything nice
to say don't say anything at all so five
star reviews are welcome the rest of you
should just move on and find something
you like we used to say keep my name out
your mouth
I like that that's good if you don't
have anything nice to say
that's good that's good I like it and uh
of course the other thing you can do
share of the show click the share button
share the link or uh just share where
you're listening to the show which radio
station or television station or TBN or
whatever it is that you're listening and
watching let people know please we would
appreciate it it is you are our
marketing plan uh we're not spending 300
million dollars a year we don't have our
own football stadium like something
um pardon me but yeah um it's uh there's
other people that do that buy your love
uh we just take care of you and love you
and then you uh will spread the word for
us we know you'll do it thank you Sarah
is in Reno hi Sarah how are you
hi yeah good evening how you guys doing
better than we deserve how can we help
um so I
am kind of in a pickle-ish picklish I
um I currently work in the dental field
as an RDA I make roughly about 4 200 a
month
um if I work a full month I'm sorry I'm
ignorant what is an RDA
oh I'm sorry registered dental assistant
thank you okay I feel better now okay
um so
um I make about 4 200 a month if I work
a full month of about you know 40 hours
a week
um the thing is about every other month
the doctor that I work for will take
about a week off which turns my income
to about 3 700 to 3 900 a month
um some of the benefits I get from
working there is I get a 401K Roth with
employer match of three percent
um I have a 16 paid vacation days and
then free to discounted Dental
um recently I took on a second job as a
server at a restaurant
and um I've only been there maybe about
two weeks and I was offered
um an assistant manager position
so for the assistant manager position
um
the offer is 6600 a month um so it's
salary based
um with a 500 bonus each month and I
only the only benefit is medical there's
no 401K no vision or dental and there
also is like paid sick days and paid
vacation days how old are you
I'm 32. when you're 52 which one are you
going to be wanting that you're glad you
did
so that's kind of where I'm at I
I love working in Dental
um I don't you know but
where I work I think I've I've outgrown
it well is there another practice you
could pursue
I mean if this person is taking off work
so often it's making your income
fluctuate have you kind of look to see
what else is out there in that same
field I'm guessing you went to school
for this
I did um yeah and I have I have no debt
um I've been debt free for um actually a
year now and upon baby step three very
good um
so I mean
I could but the thing is I wouldn't be
making as much money and I don't want
you to do this for the money I don't
want you I don't want you to do that I
don't know if you're going to be making
more money or not you haven't looked
yeah well no no I have I have researched
around where I work now and
um in Reno and I I wouldn't I wouldn't
be making much more um but here's here's
my biggest Factor that's kind of has me
on the fence is I'm a single mom of four
so
I like my server position
um everyone I work with seems to be
really awesome
so I I guess my dilemma is like I'm not
so much worried about the 401K because I
could you know roll over into an IRA
listen the benefit the benefits don't
matter the benefits don't matter yeah
what matters is if you if you take a job
making twice what you're making now
and you and it is not a long-term play
then you have to have an extra strategy
and uh you did not wake up
six weeks ago and say I want to be a
restaurant manager yeah you fell into
this
this was not an act of intentionality
no you did not seek this out to fulfill
a dream of being a restaurant manager
right I haven't no I haven't I wasn't
which tells me the only thing the the
number one thing that's attracting you
is the money
well here's the thing why can't you why
can't you do the the RDA job and and
keep looking and see what else is out
there that maybe pays higher maybe it
doesn't at the very least you might find
a dentist that you're working with
that's not taking so many days off you
know that's closing up the office
um but why can't you just if you like
this restaurant so much why can't you
just work there on Saturdays
or you know um as a side you know I mean
just something you're doing on the side
why does it have to be your full-time
job because can't can't you take your
salary that you're making from the
dental thing and can't you take whatever
little side hustle money and can't that
equal the same thing that doing the
restaurant full-time equals
yeah so that's the thing is like right
now I'm working at the restaurant and um
as an RDA and I'm making
I mean I just started again I just
started the server position but I but
you know when I did the math I make
about 6 500 to 7 000
um with both jobs but I'm working 62
hours a week what is the manager's job
number of hours entail
um it would be 45 to 50. hours a week so
I'd be working uh five days a week and
then
um but yeah so I'd be working less
maybe so it would give me more time with
my kids
because I mean I'm stretched right now
it's just I guess a lot of it is like I
can save this money get get my baby
stuff three moving way faster be able to
save more
um to buy to you know to purchase a home
here within you know the next year and a
half or two years
um and just
I just want to put my kids and ever and
me and on the right track and just I
mean I love Dental but I just I don't
know I think I'm just kind of outgrowing
it and I've I have like wanted to be I
assume I assume you have a uh I just I
assume you have a certification
I do
what does it take to maintain the
certification
I just uh go online I pay it and it's
renewed every two years so even if I
went out of dental I would be able to go
back if it didn't work out at any time
that's what I'm thinking yeah yep at any
time because here here's what here's
what I I you're in the honeymoon phase
over there
so you don't see any downsides
um and I got to tell you the restaurant
business is some of the hardest work
you'll ever get in in your life yep very
hard work
and when they tell when they tell you 50
when they tell you 50 hours they don't
mean it
especially in management you're going to
be as soon as a server doesn't show on a
shift when you're not there they're
going to call you as a system manager
come in and cover for the server
you're going to be there more than 50
hours
and your own salary
oh yeah so then it's like yeah
Dave is not wrong about that
and I just don't want you to you're all
Starry Eyed about this Sarah and I I'm
not trying to kill your dream but I
don't think it's just it's not as plush
as you think it is but if you want to go
do it it's not the end of the world
because here's the thing you probably
can go get a job as a dental assistant
in about 20 minutes if this doesn't work
out
yeah and I'm I'm great at my job I mean
I do I mean you can get a job in that
field no problem you can get a job in
that field almost any time at will
and I think you'll be able to find that
if something happens here so yeah I'm
going to get proper notice and I guess
you go try it but I want you to try it
with a little bit more I mean you're
acting like this is some kind of huge
upgrade in lifestyle and huge upgrade in
money and it's not any of that
have you really played the numbers out
of this like have you ever written this
out and really looked at how it's going
to move the needle for you or is this
just something that's been floating
around in your brain if you haven't done
that get it on paper and really play out
the numbers to what your goals are you
said that you want to get your emergency
fund you said you want to save for a
house play out these numbers and see
where you land I think that you might
realize it's not the leap that you think
it's going to be yeah it's okay to try
it but I I disagree with the level of
excitement you've got over it
and I want you to win I love you I want
you to do great okay I want you to be
out there but I I think um you got a
pretty plush gig now the one you're
going into is a lot tougher this
is the Ramsay show Dave here you can
find all of our shows with the Ramsay
Network app on your smartphone it's the
only place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships this is the
Ramsey show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host Nate is in Baltimore hi Nate how
are you
hey Dave G how are you guys better than
we deserve what's up
oh great glad to hear that I'm calling
because uh my wife and I just recently
very recently got out of uh debt after a
long journey here and um we're we're
wondering if we should uh continue to
rent and remain debt free or if we
should uh would you recommend us go
ahead and buying a house and we've been
warning for a long time
um and if so are you cool with us
spending 800k on it because the houses
the housing crisis here in Maryland are
through the roof and the kind of house
we want is sort of in that range and
then in addition
if we buy what should we work on next is
it the mortgage or what would you
recommend I mean are you guys it sounds
like you kind of have been are you a
listener of our steps it sounds like
you've been walking through the steps
you're out of baby step two do you have
three to six months saved
of expenses
we we do okay that's good all right have
you worked on a down payment separate
from that three to six months
yeah so we our down payment is is going
to be and the three to six months is all
lumped into uh what we obtained from the
sale of hotels that's kind of how we
finished off our debt
it's all lumped in from sorry I missed
that last part
oh okay so how much money is in your
account right now
um about 160 okay okay how much of that
is your how much is that should be your
rainy day fund
uh yeah I didn't do the math on that for
okay three to six months of your monthly
expenses what's your household income
so we're 280k okay uh probably three to
six months of expenses might be a like
40 000 bucks you set that aside never
touch it it's just for emergencies
all right okay you said you had 160 in
there so that leaves 120 to put down did
I do that right that's right okay and
you make really really good money
congratulations
and so if we and the house you sold sold
for how much
creating okay so you're doubling house
going from 400 to 800.
yeah okay which also tells me that there
are four hundred thousand dollar houses
in Baltimore
my wife said you would say that just
just for anyone wondering yeah no just
just in case uh just you know just in
case I ever hear any rationalizing
language coming out of you again
however I think you can actually afford
an 800 000 house with the guidelines
that we use yeah so you know the way we
teach is we want you we don't want your
payment to be any more than 25 of your
take home and I mean that's everything
included we're talking about your taxes
your insurance yeah 15 year so put down
120 000 on 800 that's going to put us at
680 the payment on a 15-year fixed that
is no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay we are okay with with the
goal then of putting 15 of your income
into retirement and starting with any
other income you can get your hands on
let's go ahead and pay that house off in
the next few years and make that part of
your wonderful wealth building plan and
Nate there's a great calculator we have
it's called how much home can I afford
and you can really put the numbers in
there and see it and play around with
that because there's you can probably
afford eight hundred you know thousand
dollars you can afford a 680 000
mortgage making 280 with the numbers
we're talking about
it's exciting you can do that I mean
because you're making it's just money is
this income stable
yes it's stable good okay yeah you did
great man you're killing it so yeah you
the numbers will work but you ought to
run them out for yourself to be sure the
point of this all is a 15-year fixed you
can get paid off in eight or ten
and where your payment is only a fourth
of your take-home pay that gives you all
kinds of wiggle room to make sure your
investing is happening the next car you
pay for in cash the next vacation you
pay for in cash and by the way this year
Christmas will be in December and you
pay that in cash that's right so stuff
doesn't sneak up on you you leave room
in your budget to be able to pay cash
for things so there's no future debt
sneaking up on you because you became
house poor right and that's the whole
reason for this formula but I think
you're in good shape I think you're able
to do it that's exciting that's really
exciting stuff very well Susie is next
up in San Antonio hi Susie how are you
hi hello hello I cannot believe I'm on
here well we're glad you're here how can
we help you all the time yes
um so I just probably like two questions
should I help my boyfriend pay off his
debt I know you're very against that
we're not no
no I thought you said you listen to this
show
I I just I miss you for I mean
I I know I know I I hear
um but let me give you a little
background no we've been together yeah
okay
I have a I have a son and we've been
living together for that amount of time
uh we bought lunch
he is six six years old okay so why are
we married
that we're I know we're doing everything
backwards we plan on we're not going to
have this huge wedding we're just gonna
do probably go to the courthouse and
then show Friday
I mean Friday Friday it's been six years
painter get off the line you get married
on Friday you can pay off his debt on
Friday
that's true that's true well the reason
why is that because we're trying to save
up for our future homes being married
does not prohibit you from saving look
all causes you to save yes
you're talking about Good Things what
you're talking about are good ideas but
they need to be done the correct way all
right you guys right and you're you're
saving up for a house right now you're
putting aside money he's putting aside
money there's no house until you get
married right now you're trying to pay
off debt he's paying off his debt you're
paying off your debt until you get
married
and I know that it feels like you're
already married because you got a kid
and you're probably living together and
all these things but legally that's not
the case
you're completely leaving yourself
vulnerable and I love you too much to do
that it's um if you were my little
sister I would say don't pay this guy's
bills unless right you're married to him
and I think you I think you already
mayor I think you're already married and
everything except legal mm-hmm right
basically I mean so you need to just do
it put the bills on bills on everything
and I so do it I'm debt free I I've I've
paid off everything so I know like if I
help them we can finish
by the end of this Friday Susie Friday
yeah what stuff hey what's stopping it
is it you or is it him or is it both no
I I think it's him I think it's mainly
because he doesn't have the money to
give me like I guess the ring or the
wedding or whatever he gave you a kid I
know right no no no this this actually
isn't his it's not his kid oh he's uh
he's The Stepfather yes yes I thought
you said it I thought you said you've
been together that long
definitely this guy's a keeper this is a
guy's a keeper he's raising somebody
else's kid rope him exactly Friday
exactly exactly but don't pay off that
debt before don't you write checks on
him to you no you do not pay other
people's bills until you're married you
will get burned you'll change the tone
the tenor the feel of the relationship
if you want to screw up a friendship
loan somebody a bunch of money messes up
everything don't do it go get married
Friday and solve this
thank you
[Music]
well I'm excited to announce
a huge event that we're doing here at
the Ramsey Event Center in May
um Mike Rowe from Dirty Jobs and I have
over the last two or three years had a
lot of wonderful conversations have
become friends we have this
both have a love affair with hard work
work ethic
persistence perseverance so we know that
in today's crazy world small business
owners are facing setbacks everywhere
they turn since 2021 we've seen four
million people a month leave their jobs
political political Economist Nick
eberstadt tells us there are seven
million able-bodied males
my copy says men but I'm going to call
them males because they're able-bodied
males opting to sit at home being
supported by someone else instead of
working they are not in the unemployment
statistics because they're not actively
seeking employment
so why are people giving up on work
there's this drift to mediocrity that is
plaguing America right now because
people aren't finding meaning in their
work
because socialism and this idea that
someone owes me as something a
participation trophy is on the rise our
government told us told some of you that
you were not essential I don't know of
any more demeaning dignity stealing
phrase that we've come up with then you
are not essential
and uh Decades of bad leadership bad
government decreased engagement quiet
quitting the great resignation this is
chaos people productivity is down
complacency is that an all-time high and
small business owners are stuck in the
middle of it all they're trying to hire
in a market where there's just very few
hard-working people looking for a job
and they don't know how to move forward
without a team to charge the gates of
hell with them
but the antidote to fear is Hope and we
need a healthy dose I hope so here's
what we're going to do on Thursday May
the 4th I'm teaming up with micro and
five best-selling authors and experts on
the state of work in America today we're
going to address this labor crisis
head-on and we're going to get Business
Leaders solutions for how to find and
hire the right people in this
environment
right here at Ramsey we're going to do
this at the Ramsey event center right
here on the hill behind me so if you're
a business leader you do not want to
miss this event in Ramsay's brand new
event center again micro and I and this
is on Thursday night May the 4th it will
be Thursday evening at dinner on on up
into the Night tickets start at 79 and
you can register starting today at
ramseysolutions.com events you need to
be at this event
79 is a deal this is some world-class
thought leaders in this space and this
is a trouble spot in America right now
and we've got some really good ideas on
how to help with it not just name call
not just poke fun although those two
things will be really easy here I'm
ready so ramseysolutions.com
events Thomas is in Washington hi Thomas
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thank you guys for taking my call
sure
um I just want your thoughts about
people who uh retire early
and retire out of the country
um and live very well
under retirement for very cheap in
different countries that I think that
they're called expats
well expat is not just living out of the
country expat means you have given up
your American citizenship to avoid
taxation
that means it means ex-patriate like you
are no longer a patriot that's what
expat means so uh okay I I would not do
that but I would you know if you want to
live in another country because the cost
of living is low and you want to live in
Costa Rica or you want to live in Mexico
and some of the spots are really nice uh
and I'm very aware of several people
doing that I've Got Friends that live in
Cabo full-time uh and yes the cost of
living is way less and uh you're but as
an American citizen you're always going
to have your taxes you're not getting
out of that uh but uh you know now
granted if there is a low cost of living
in another country there's some things
that go with that
okay a lower standard of living
word do you have in mind Thomas
uh about Costa Rica Ecuador
um
uh not Venezuela that's for sure
you know Mexico is is good maybe uh an
Asian country like Thailand or Vietnam
it's very cheap yeah just do your
research and go to these places
what I would do is a couple things one
is I would go to the area that narrowed
down to two or three areas and go rent a
house there for a month
a month okay not just a week a month
yeah to wear your your pulse rate
changes you your body adjusts to the
rhythm of the culture that you're living
in
and
um it I I've got a buddy that owns a
thousand acres in Costa Rica it's
actually hectares but not Acres but um
and uh he's planning to do what you do
and when he goes down there he says his
pulse rate changes but he has to stay
several weeks for that to happen and
here's the deal you can build a yeah a
compound so to speak have a very nice
property and the cost of Labor might be
really low so you might have lots of
folks helping you inside the property
right as Maids or as chefs or doing the
lawn work or whatever but when you leave
the compound when you leave your
property you're going to go to a
different standard of living than you
are in the state of Washington
so you've got to enjoy the culture the
culture the shopping the restaurants
you've gotta be fine with all of that
and you can be I'm not saying you can't
but but the idea of the concern guys is
the uh like Healthcare in different
countries too exactly that's that's a
that's a part of it yeah
that's a part of it and and you know
you're gonna uh but it's quite an
adventure and I don't I don't uh I I
would not do it because I hate America I
would do it because it's a fun adventure
no I don't hate it I love America okay
I'm just saying I'm just you asked my
opinion so I'm telling you but the uh uh
and I wouldn't do it to become an
ex-patriate to where I don't have you
know I lose my citizenship to give up on
taxes that's not the point I'm not
trying to hide I'm not trying to become
you know Off the Grid I'm just trying to
enjoy a high I mean a good standard of
living for a lot less money yeah man I
would to be able to have a property
outside of the United States and keep a
residence in the United States that for
me would be
The Best of Both Worlds and you can
divide up your time I don't know what
Thomas's money situation is like but
that to me is where it's at but I would
um
spend based on the the circles I run in
the mistakes that people have made or
where they thought it was something
until they lived there and so go live
there before you drop you know a half
million dollars a million dollars
whatever it is into a property
um and or because it was a honeymoon
period too enamored yeah you got to get
you gotta start to understand like
you know if you live in Cabo and you
call a plumber
okay yeah it's not three hours
it's three days before they come yeah
wow okay so yeah and maybe that's the
other thing so it's true it's a
different cult I mean you know when they
say in Jamaica no problem mon yes and no
timings ain't coming yeah yeah that's
Island time right there I'm smoking pot
I am not going to come help you that's
what that means that's true
you gotta you know so somebody's wired
like me where the trains run on time and
I like high service and I like I like to
you know I like the water to not get
empty on my table while I'm in a
restaurant and you know I'm not
demanding I'm just spoiled yeah and so
you know you just gotta have a little
more laid-back mentality if you're going
to be in a different culture because uh
you know some some of the uh Caribbean
cultures don't run on the same speed
sure that we run on in the U.S and uh
most of them don't and it's quite
wonderful uh as long as you adjust your
ex expectations to it so that that's the
point so live there a little while
little um
it'll help you make a better decision
wherever it is whether it's Thailand or
uh whatever consider politics too yeah
I'd be worrying about the politics you
know it would be and the stability of
the government yeah there's a particular
location all those kinds of things this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Scott
and Sherry are with us hey guys how are
you hey good welcome welcome where do
you guys live uh brookendale New York
love it and welcome to Nashville how
much debt have you paid off sixty four
thousand eight hundred and two dollars
and 88 cents very good how long did this
take 28 months 26 days I love it and
what was your range of income during
that two and a half years 91 to 99
000. cool what do you all do for a
living I'm a teacher Aid bus driver I'm
a registered nurse very good good for
you guys what kind of debt was your 65
000. three credit cards personal loans
student loans two vehicles you were
normal
covered that
I'm through okay 28 months ago how long
you all been married 27 years 27 years
but 25 years into the marriage you
looked up and said this plan's got to
change tell me what happened
um
I had a I had Facebook for the first
time and I saw one of my friends had
posted pictures of her and her family
holding wads and wads of money and they
paid cash for uh new to them SUV and I
said how did you do that you know
because that was something that I always
wanted to do lots and lots of money is
good yeah like all of them yeah yeah and
because I always thought that
buying a car with cash was what older
people did not people my age and yeah
rich people or something yes yep so I
approached Scott and said you know I
think that we could do this and I ended
up um totaling up all of our debt uh-oh
and I told him about it and uh I think
the rest is history so what was your
reaction Scott when she comes to you
with 65 000 yeah it was overwhelming
um and I read your book and we took off
and I knew that I had to finish this I
had to do it it was something that
I've watched people do and we decided we
got to give it a shot and we never
stopped we took FPU
um and I promised the FPU teacher that I
would do this that would be here
wow very cool where did you take
Financial Peace University
um in Ithaca New York okay at your
church or a church it was through a
church a church okay very good very cool
okay so this all starts with a innocent
Facebook post
good things can can come from Facebook
that's right it's the first time I found
one yeah yeah it can actually happen I
agree all right wads and wads of cash we
pay cash for an SUV so Sherry says uh
hey friend how'd you do this and she
said those Ramsey people and you get The
Total Money Makeover book which leads
you into a financial peace class have I
got this right yep and we're now
Financial Peace University teachers
through our coordinators through our uh
Church
oh where what's your church Hillside
Alliance all right you need to go to
this you need to go to Scott and
Sherry's class they're professionals
they paid off 65 000 in debt and they
have wads and watts of cash
we're working on that yeah I love it way
to go you two we're so proud of y'all
thank you so when you guys were getting
out of debt what did you find did you
find that man it's our income we've got
to do things to get more money in or was
it really getting on a budget and
decreasing you know your out go it was
getting on the budget we were already
following the every dollar app and
paying for that and then we just did the
class to give us even more inspiration
and more push
um so and then just cutting back on a
lot of things like we love to go out to
dinner we love to travel
um so we cut back on all of that
the best camping trip we had was when we
took our camper debt free hey to a free
campsite somewhere and just stayed in
our camper nobody else's yeah I like it
that's good nobody else owns it yeah
meaning you've got it paid off and now
we own the truck that pulls it and the
Subaru that got us here and
it's unbelievable yeah feels different
the cars drive different without a
payment they do I you know I can hit a
deer which are you know it's very common
up in New York have you hit one in the
past okay not lately no that happens in
Tennessee too they're like rats around
here they're everywhere yeah I was the
spender you know it was always me I ate
out more than I should and it showed in
two ways we were broke and
oh my gosh way to go you guys very good
way to go how's it feel to be free for
the first time in 27 years it feels it
feels really good my dad always told me
especially when we pulled up into the
driveway with a new car new to us car
um he was always like slave to the
lender slave to the lender and I was
like
like yeah I'm that's normal that's
that's when I can afford a car wow now
you can afford one though now we can
afford one if you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else yeah and I think that that I mean
besides paying off the debt um giving
was our that was our oh that's our
ultimate goal
it is kind of fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes it is
so what's next
kit like what's that thing that you're
like okay we're debt free now it's go
time on this uh the roof is leaking and
we're gonna pay cash for that hey love
it that's just really yeah that's
awesome that's a great feeling it really
is okay so talk to people
uh because you guys have been married 27
years I've been married 40. talk to
people that have been married uh a
couple decades how did it change after
25 years of marriage when you start
working on this how did it change your
relationship
we got closer
our kids are we are a younger kid
um graduated HVAC School Heating and
ventilation air conditioning and watched
this whole process and
he will never have a credit card or
he'll be he wants to be debt free like
us and it's changed our future but it's
hopefully going to change his forever so
amen
um just but there were a lot of mornings
that we would get up and sit with our
with your book open and we would with
our Bibles open and study and read those
verses over and over again
and you know just work on that and
praying the promises of God over your
life yes and now you see a whole
different you catch a whole another gear
in your marriage and in your
relationship
um you don't have any payments you can
be generous you've changed your family
tree because your kids are watching and
now they're changing and not going to do
it it's pretty incredible the uh the
effect that all of this has from one
stinking Facebook post
and can I call out something in you
guys's character that's that's worth
calling out a lot of people would have
seen that post Sherry and gone oh must
be nice and hated on it and thought well
that's but you asked how
and I think that that's something that
is just so
um there's not a stitch of pride in that
it's so humble to go well how'd you do
it and not be mad at him and not be
jealous at him and not oil must be nice
because so many people would do that and
I just think that right there is
incredible oh thank you very well done
they gave us the book that I read as
well so when she said that that was the
book that was handed to me oh wow
amazing they still hand books out today
they sold the house and left a book in
the house in the drawer and they sold it
and so they sort of do those little
tricks along the way so hopefully
someday we can do something like that I
love that Johnny Total Money Makeover
seed yeah I like it I like it I love it
a lot well done well done very cool well
speaking of books we've got the live and
give bundle for you guys The Total Money
Makeover for you to give away and like
it's happened for you pay it forward and
we're gonna help you do that by giving
you that the baby steps millionaires
book because that's your next step and
Financial Peace University since you're
a coordinators we're going to give you a
membership you can give that to somebody
I'm sure you know a single mom or
somebody that's deserving that needs
some help and get them going so you'll
find good uses for all of that you guys
are special you're amazing people we're
so proud of you thank you for coming
thank you all right Scott and Sherry
Ithaca New York 65 000 paid off in 28
months making 91 to 99 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
yeah
yeah that's all that's done
this is the Ramsay show
oh
[Music]
our scripture of the day
Psalms 143 10 teach me to do your will
for you are my God
may your good spirit lead me on level
ground
Mark Twain said don't let schooling
interfere with your education
good stuff Candace is with us in Dallas
hey Candace welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi my question is
um then well the next thing on our to-do
list Financial to-do list is to get term
life insurance and part of the pricing
for that depends on your weight but I'm
um two weeks away from having my third
baby
so I'm curious if I should
either
use my pre-pregnancy weight to fill
these applications that or the the tools
out or if I should wait until after our
baby is born and
um and you know give it some time to
so that I get back down to a
more normal weight for myself before I
um before I go and get a policy
ethically either one's okay with me in
terms of uh how much Insurance are you
applying for
probably about 1.3 mil
okay if they're going to require a
medical they may put you on a scale
and if they're going to do that then
you're going to have to wait till post
baby right
right and so uh what I would do are you
working with Xander insurance
where I went good good call them and ask
them what they think you should do on
this particular policy with this
particular carrier and they can give you
some guidance if you're going to get put
on a scale you know because they're
coming to check your blood pressure
they're going to do an in-home medical
and on a million dollar policy they
might okay how old are you
I'm 39. any other Medical
no okay so healthy mother of three okay
soon to be soon to be okay yeah so I
would talk to them about that if there
is a an in-house uh you know the number
of times I've had a medical exam for
life insurance there's so many I can't
count them anymore over the years so
um but it's always
you know they're they're looking for
uh blood pressure they're looking at
weight and uh BMI you know body mass
index and so on and so uh you know if
they're okay with you filling it out
with your pre-pregnancy weight that's
not really unethical because that is
your actual weight
right you know I mean
um what you're going through here is a
normal transformational process of
having a baby so that's not not wrong
but now again if they're going to have
they're going to come three weeks after
the baby comes and do a medical then you
know you probably just need to wait if
that's the case obviously
so I would talk to them let them talk
you through it yeah I would do the same
thing you would think that there would
be something that's kind of in place for
that sort of situation because like you
said having a baby is a natural thing it
doesn't mean you're unhealthy or that
you're quote overweight yeah well weight
gain would be you would need to gain
weight exactly that that's the healthy
State yeah to gain weight so I mean
third baby sometimes a little more I've
heard a rumor but I don't know but for
some people who will remain nameless
second baby
I don't know this person I do not know
this person look those bmis that they
measure You by yeah that's real yes but
it's completely unfair it's unfair thank
you Dave it's unfair because muscle
weighs more than fat okay well I mean
and did you know that old fat weighs
even more
I'll take your word for it ancient fat
all right Jim is in Pittsburgh hey Jim
what's up
hey thank you for having me on and thank
you for everything you do thank you yeah
quick question a quick question about
baby step six my wife and I are in four
five and six good and uh we just moved
into the house and we projected we could
probably knock out the mortgage in five
to eight years if we live pretty
frugally two-part question though
how intense do you generally recommend
for baby step six number one and number
two are we better with that time window
of putting the money directly at the
mortgage or putting it in let's say an s
p fund letting it grow and then in five
or six years taking that and putting it
at the uh principal last question first
directly at the mortgage and there's a
reason why and for me it's you know
you'd probably be putting that money in
some sort of a brokerage account and I
just don't like the idea Jim of having a
big pile of money sitting there because
I say it all the time the minute you've
got forty thousand sixty thousand this
guy named Uncle Booboo walks in and he's
giving you all these great ideas on what
you should do with that money and
instead of doing what you said you were
going to do which is put it towards a
mortgage so there's nothing wrong with
just going ahead and chunking that more
that money to the mortgage in real time
um now back to your first question the
baby six thing the intensity you know we
say around here that the first few baby
steps are about being intense and then
the the second few are about
intentionality and that's true but I
think you know some people maybe baby
step two wasn't a huge deal for them and
so they're they're ready to put some
intensity into something and a lot of
times that looks like the mortgage
um and if that's the case and you and
your wife are like hey we really want to
get this thing paid off I really think
that's up to you guys I I personally you
know me and my husband were working to
pay off a mortgage and I would say we're
kind of at that if if intensity is
measured you know from one to 100 we're
like 50 60 we're not doing it the way we
did baby step two you know we're we're
being very intentional about putting
extra money making extra payments but
it's not beans and rice rice and beans
here's the thing
um extreme frugality is hard to sustain
for six or eight years that too
emotionally
because you're not participating in ever
going out to eat you're not you're not
ever going on a vacation you're not
you're driving an old beat up car you're
not buying uh much clothing at all
um and that's an extreme frugality and
intention an intensity that would be
gazelle intents and baby steps one two
three right so if you know I would not
recommend extreme in that I wouldn't
personally do extreme but I am very goal
oriented and every time you spend money
on something it means you're not
reducing the mortgage and you're going
to have it that much longer so I'm gonna
that that's the intentionality piece I'm
gonna constantly be making that weighted
decision and some people call that
Frugal I call it being a grown-up being
you know so maybe instead of a Frugal
vacation a modest vacation something
like that yeah I mean uh you know like I
don't want you making 300 000 a year and
and you know uh staying in some rat
hotel that's just silly I mean you don't
do that it's not it's not sustainable
and if you want to do that for 18 months
or something but for six years that's
that's a problem
you know it's it's very hard to to
sustain that relationally now what
because what I'm what I have found and
doing what I do is one person might be
able to do that but the other one is not
along for a joyride and you start it
starts leaving a mark a scar on your
relationships at some point the extreme
part does now if you're both in and you
say hey instead of spending this doing
this glorious uh seven-day Cruise uh
we're going to do a weekend and a nice
air in B and B yeah or we're going to
you know catch a a deal on a a nice
hotel for four days and uh spend half
and put the other half on there that
that's intentionality that's not
intensity and so that's not extreme
frugality that's just paying attention
yeah and we did do all that kind of
stuff that's a good point because I know
for Sam and I when I I remember trying
to come in hot with the mortgage stuff
and the look on his face was like PTSD
like we just we just did this like I
just wanted enjoy a little bit and he
was right yeah and a little bit is the
case so yeah this going Hog Wild as soon
as you get out of debt is going to get
you back into that so that that's not
what we're talking about we're going to
be intentional we'll be doing this
within with purpose but I think you guys
as long as you and your wife are both at
peace and one of you is not dragging the
other one yeah true through this then I
think you got a pretty good balance at
that point so some level of frugality
what the culture calls frugality yes
right the culture spends like they're in
Congress well that's a good point
because these
deaths are different frugality in my
mind is very different than what some
people might say you know frugality in
some people's mind is I don't get
everything I want
but that's not what he's talking about
and so we need to be careful because I
don't want you dumpster diving and ramen
noodles and you know sewing up your
clothes and making 400 000 a year and uh
and calling that responsible yeah no
that's terrible that's not what we're
doing nope not during not doing four or
five six now during one through three we
can do anything you want to do
that puts us out of the Rams are showing
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]